It's time for Drew's News,
your daily swing in that good news hammock.
(Drew exhales)
(Ross laughs)
And with me at the desk, my trustee co-pilot,
I'm the luckiest girl in the world,
Rossy Ross Matthews.
Aww.
That makes me the luckiest boy in the world.
Hi guys, hi. Shoot.
(audience applauds)
First up, Joshua Jackson, you know,
Pacey from "Dawson's Creek."
Oh, I know, yeah.
And he was on "The Affair."
Everybody loves "The Affair."
Well, he's all grown up now, as we know,
and he has a steamy new role on the new TV reboot
of, get ready for this one, "Fatal Attraction."
Ooh, this is a good one.
Where has this been all these years?
Oh my God. I'm so into the concept.
Great idea.
I'm not gonna be ignored,
Dan.
Dan. (laughs)
Oh my God. It's the best movie ever.
So there's lots of sexy scenes in it,
and one fan who can't wait to watch is his wife.
That's right, Insider reports that Jodie Turner-Smith
says she loves washing Joshua's love scenes
because he is a sex symbol, and in real life,
that's right, that's how she sees him,
and she wants him to lean into it.
Ms. Turner-Smith said,
(audience cheers)
and I quote.
Really?
"I can't wait to see my husband
blankety-blanking on screen again.
Did you watch "The Affair"?
That's her quote.
Uh-huh.
Ross, thoughts?
Well, that's evolved.
You were are all clapping, like, "Great for her."
Okay, good, but if that was your husband or your wife,
would you wanna watch them in a love scene
with somebody else?
Nah-ah-ah. No.
I'm not a jealous type of person,
but if my Wellingthon is watching, try it, no.
I think this is fun because she's made it
an empowering, sexy thing.
She could feel like a victim,
that she felt bad that her husband does this,
but I think her spin is quite sexy and empowering.
I'm in.
Okay, I'm in, too.
All right, next up.
So I'm Ross Matthews, your reality TV reporter,
and I've got some fresh scoop.
Anyone here watch "Love is Blind"?
Everybody is talking
about this show.
(audience applauds)
Well, I actually watched the first part of the reunion
on the train in today of "Love is Blind."
I'm obsessed, and if you are too,
but you're upset it's ending, turn that frow upside down,
'cause "The Ultimatum" is a new show.
People reports, Netflix's newest reality show
premieres April 6th.
Nick and Vanessa Lachey, who host "Love is Blind,"
they're back at the helm of this one,
and here's the premise.
They start with six couples who are on
the verge of marriage, but one person in each couple
is not so sure.
And then they have eight weeks to figure it out,
but there's a little twist.
Listen to what happens.
They will each pick a new partner from the group
and try living with that person as a couple
to see what life would be like with somebody else.
Ooh!
I feel the exact opposite way
as I do about Jodie Turner-Smith.
This is a recipe for disaster.
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
It makes me so uncomfortable.
It is so uncomfortable to think about this,
and I am so angry that I will watch every second of this,
every single second.
Are you gonna hate watch it?
I am, of course.
I mean, it just seems like a disaster waiting to happen.
Yes.
Sabotage!
And I'm sure it's gonna get high ratings.
It is, yes, but it also begs the question
about ultimatums in general.
You know what I mean?
I didn't think about it from that perspective, Rossy.
Well, think about that.
If you are in a relationship and one of you is like,
"Let's get married, let's get married,"
and the other person is dragging their feet,
I have a spoiler alert,
it's probably not gonna end well, right?
Because if somebody doesn't wanna marry you,
what else do you need to know?
So that being said, I'm sure this show
is going to be a hit.
I will report back to you every detail.
(upbeat music)